what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to Jimmy Kimmel
interviewing kids about the pay Gap
because who knows better than children
about society's biggest issues anyways
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and sign up to our
membership tiers to support the channel
equal pay is an issue that could affect
many uh generations of Americans and
since children are our future according
to the song anyway I thought it would be
a good idea to get their take on it so
we went out on the street we asked kids
to explain why they think women get paid
less than men and this is what they had
to say it's such a disingenuous argument
they're the Next Generation so let's ask
them let me okay kit the next generation
of children are going to be involved in
foreign policy decisions blessing do you
think it's cool to ask kids about
foreign policy
do you think you think that makes sense
let's ask the kids let's interview the
children
why do you think women get paid less
than men for the same jobs oh she's so
cute girls don't work as hard as the
boys
[Laughter]
ah she's red pill oh she
[Music]
that's true we work Less hours
oh that's so funny the interview is
gonna try to fix it hold let's see what
are they doing instead of working hard
and doing other stuff
red pill child
young pearly things yeah this is a
couple years old where is she now come
on the channel what kind of other stuff
texting and running on the track
[Laughter]
she knows she knows
women get paid less than men
um maybe women aren't acting as they
should maybe they're acting weird so
people think that they're
shouldn't be treated as fairly as men
would be how come the women make less
money than men because probably some
women in California don't really have
jobs
I like how the kids they're trying to
get these like liberal answers and the
kids know oh this is I was not expecting
this I didn't watch this before
why do you think that women make less
money than men I think these are very
underrated because they can do more but
people expect them to do less
I can just see the future liberal child
because they can do more but they
explorate our child
well a lot of people underestimate them
and they could do so much more see the
programming has already started I gave
the other kids so blah you gotta get you
gotta get your mic so they can hear you
he was saying he was saying that the
other kids got claps and that or that he
got claps and the other kids didn't get
claps I clapped for the other kids
There's jobs that men can too that women
can like what
like they can be an actress if they want
and a man can't be an actress
they can they can do whatever their
heart tells them to do but you know what
they're not doing Plumbing bricklaying
working at an oil rig what about this
kid you think all right let's see it
gets paid less a woman might like maybe
like do stuff a little bit wrong but
she's still
um gets paid less what
I like how
oh yeah she do stuff a little bit wrong
because maybe she doesn't know those
stuff and maybe they don't teach her
those stuff but the guy knows that stuff
yes
I like how these kids are just like red
pills
and then then the adults program them
that's that's what happens do you think
women are not as good at jobs as men
what a loaded question to ask a
five-year-old
laughs
it's like you gotta ask the
five-year-old all right I they're very
good and they work all the time like my
mom
they work too who worked harder
mom
[Applause]
um
why are you shaking your head blessing
why do you speaking you have a mic you
have a mic I just randomly picked this
today I was like oh yeah I forgot about
that well yeah I was saying it's crazy
how all these kids that are saying all
these facts about men men working hard
and women not working hard they know
that stuff are not getting clips
give some kids some claps
yeah what about equal claps equal clap
I think we're gonna make that happen
maybe let's see if we have like a good a
good group of people to help around the
world or maybe a good president who
could help and who would be a good
president to help with that
um probably Donald Trump
[Applause]
okay
[Laughter]
oh that's so funny
because
you can
fun fact I'm pretty sure Donald Trump
had more women in his cabinet than any
other sitting president U.S president I
don't I mean let me let me know in the
chat if that's correct but I'm pretty
sure if he thinks of women and men same
and equal and he also was the first
um guy to have a woman lead like a big
architectural project in New York I
remember they did like a documentary on
it why do you think women make less
money than men for the same jobs
is this giving you a headache
why do you think that women make less
money than men what do you I feel like
she's going to give a woke answer I
don't know I think it's the glasses well
probably because women care about
shopping
um
General truths are just acknowledged by
children you know what I mean like it's
kind of funny how they they like are
smarter than adults sometimes because
they know basic truths and then we like
brainwash them into saying oh no women
do work exactly as hard or they you know
effects
work
and so you think that they're kind of
slacking off at work shopping online and
that's
yeah
so true
when I worked in sales I would look I
would chop online sometimes
sorry Konica
I quit but you know I'm a YouTuber now
this is better
have you ever seen that happen
no but I think it I don't think that
women make less money than men
uh because men work harder harder and
like real estate and other jobs how do
you know that
because my dad's a real estate agent
I like how they want the kids to give
these woke answers but they're all get
there
okay some claps
[Applause]
seeing a female real estate agent uh yes
I've seen a couple and you think they
don't work as hard
I think this Lounge
[Laughter]
less money than men because all the men
make all the decisions and make all the
rules
and it's always male presidents
and there's never a female president if
there was a female president do you
think all that would change probably a
little bit do you think that'll ever
happen this is unequal clapping
and equal clapping we gotta let the
children like they're kids we're
supposed to clap for that
[Laughter]
why do you think women make less money
than men for the same jobs
oh the rose is a messed up place
[Applause]
[Laughter]
to say they deserve this they deserve
this because they were trying to use
children to promote their agenda and
children are red pill until their
parents brainwash them they are red pill
but they said the shop
uh guys let me know in the comments what
I should react to next subscribe to the
channel ring that notification Bell and
this is what happens when you use
children to promote your woke agenda
like the video on your way out and I'll
talk to you next time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible